if you were kidnapped and forced to play
brutal death games every night what
would you do i'm here to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the death games in alice in
borderland this kid is about to realize
that danger is around every corner this
spiky-haired student arisu wakes up on
an empty beach with two other friends
they find themselves inside an overgrown
city where there are no signs of human
life searching a convenience store the
reality begins to sink in that they're
in some sort of dream or so they think
arisu tells the others that they've now
got the freedom to do whatever they want
but all this freedom will come at a
deadly price later that night the smoker
karubi begins to worry that this dream
isn't going to end he urges the others
to start taking the situation seriously
and stop the underage drinking there's
no dream they're far away from home and
they need to get back that's when he
hears something in the distance and
realizes that they aren't the only ones
in this empty city okay if being in an
abandoned city sounds like a good idea
it might not seem so fun when we realize
there's no internet now there's not much
we can do about waking up kidnapped we
have no idea where the hell we are and
there's a good chance that the other
people are going to try and hunt us down
if other japanese death games in general
are anything to go by however we first
notice that right before we suddenly
appeared here there was a blast emitted
from those fireworks that seemingly
blinded us for a period of time however
we can clearly see now and seemingly
have no retinal damage which means that
the blast we saw was clearly not some
type of explosive ordnance since the
blast from a one megaton explosion would
be bright enough to blind anyone who
looks at it within a 53-mile radius
because these kids were clearly within
that radius it's safe to say that what
they saw was clearly something else
entirely and also we have no burns and
are not suffering from any type of acute
radiation poisoning either which if this
scenario was caused by an explosion we
likely would have at least felt
something burning on our skin by now
this means that putting aside any alien
abduction type crap someone has put us
here at least that is what i would
assume based on all the current factors
presented this means that the only
chilling i'd be doing would be to crack
open a cold one while we try and get to
the bottom of this as soon as possible
because i doubt anyone would kidnap us
into having a good time unless that spot
was in bangkok thailand and in that case
i would simply have called dom for help
instead or maybe i wouldn't yeah
probably not now using regular survival
tips as a guessing guide we can try our
best to survive as long as possible the
first thing we should do is stock up on
as much water as we can luckily for us
japan's tap water is completely safe to
drink in fact it's some of the cleanest
in the world the next thing we should do
is to look for food japan is a country
known for having large amounts of
processed food meaning the preservatives
in said food should mean that eating out
won't be too difficult now that our
basic essentials are sorted we still
need to find out where the hell we are
and again we seem to be fine from a
radiation standpoint at least for now
but i would strip my boys down to their
skivvies i mean underwear and check for
any and all rope burns consisting of
redness irritation or bleeding on the
skin to indicate if we were bound at any
point during our time while unconscious
because either we've been kidnapped by
some creepo abducted by aliens or we're
in some sick form of weeb purgatory and
if that's the case that that means we're
already dead the boys find themselves at
an overnight market excited by all the
amazing stalls available inside they
notice a booth in the middle of the
market mentioning that four entries have
been confirmed over the loudspeaker
worried carterby tells the others to
leave before anything bad happens but
that's when this mysterious lady
interrupts to warn him to not step
outside these kids look gullible as hell
and she comments that they must be new
around here she says that the world
they're in is very real and death is
around every corner she flicks the kid's
cigarette out of the market and suddenly
it disintegrates into nothing the lady
mentions that they're a part of a game
and it's just about to begin the booth
announces that the game's difficulty is
set to three of clubs and tells each
person to draw one fortune slip if
everyone draws a fortune slip they beat
the game they win not drawing a slip
though means that you fail before it
even starts the students demand that the
lady reveals everything she knows she
introduces herself as shibuki and tells
them that the three of clubs means that
the game is less dangerous the lady
mentions that they need to be aware of
every small detail if they want to stay
alive confused arizu questions her about
the rules and where the hell they even
are the lady gets angry and tells him to
figure it out himself they arrive at the
booth and the smoker decides to go first
he's given a slip that states you are
the general the person you're waiting
for is south of here the next person to
pick is chota he's given a mathematical
equation in order to write the answer
down on this slip at the same time carby
questions the lady asking her why she's
participating in another game she tells
them that they're all in the same
position and doesn't know what will
happen after the game is over but that's
when chota answers the mathematical
equation wrong the booth then announces
that a wrong answer will result in being
shot dead suddenly flaming arrows attack
the kid and almost kill him shibuki
tells them she'll go next and arizu
freaks his [ __ ] out at her that's when
she mentions that there's a time limit
if all the lamps turn off they'll lose
the game okay this is some serious
business what we thought was a little
fun game to keep us occupied is actually
going to result in our deaths if we
don't do something now looking at our
options it doesn't seem like running is
a good idea there's some sort of laser
beam wall covering our every direction
and this is going to limit our escape
opportunities now we know if we get the
mathematical equations wrong there's
going to be flaming arrows ready to burn
us alive and shred us to pieces all at
the same time great since there's no
friends in this game we should look to
our buddies and use this girl to our
advantage we don't know her and bringing
more people along in our group means
that supplies will run out even faster
however what we can do is use her body
as a sort of meat shield she doesn't
look that small of a lady and i'm pretty
sure johnny depp would agree and that
means she's perfect for us to use her as
a shield from the arrows if we have to
of course now we might not know how to
beat the game specifically but what we
do know is that the game will end once
the lamps burn out the game never
specifies whether or not we can reignite
them so let's assume that we might be
able to wait out the game until they run
out of flaming arrows the lady did tell
us to pay attention to every small
detail so this is probably our best
chance of success shibuki picks her slip
and is given another problem the lady
tells the booth her answer is 30 but
she's completely wrong suddenly hundreds
of flaming arrows are sent in their
direction arsu becomes frozen with fear
staring at a sea of death coming his way
his buddy runs over and kicks him in the
back telling him to grow some balls and
run he then suddenly decides that he
wants to live and run safely to cover
but the group then notices that chota is
still out in the open he then gets
struck in the calf by an arrow and arizu
goes to help but he notices the curse
slip drop right next to him chota's leg
catches on fire and he screams out in
pain the smoker rushes over with a pool
of water and throws it onto his
screaming friend ardus who praises his
buddy for being a hero and gets the
courage to pick out the fourth and final
slip he draws the greatest curse and the
others realize that they're done for
artesu begins to think hard looking back
at all the recent events for any clues
and suddenly he blurts out the answer as
6.9 billion the booth shows a number of
6.93 billion and tells him that the
answer is wrong but arisu has a plan he
turns around and tells everyone that the
question is impossible to answer to
begin with something is clearly wrong
the rules state that they must answer
the questions but never mentioned that
it would win them the game all they need
to do is to avoid the arrows as clearly
stated on every single slip they've been
given so far seeing the arrows coming
they grab cover and run as fast as
possible the group finds a well and
caribbe opens it to find nothing but
dirt that's when he spots a tile-like
material in the dirt and digs through to
find a wheel they head underneath and
the game congratulates them for winning
the three of clubs arisu is given a visa
showing him how many days he can stay in
the desolate city known as borderland
shibuki tells them that rumor states
there are a lot more people here than
they realize at night they all appear in
games and your visa is extended if you
win later chota spots a crazy man hiding
in this school the man blocks the door
and mentions that all his friends were
killed in the most horrifying ways
possible suddenly green beams hit the
city and arizu begins to realize the
punishment for their visas expiring the
next day the group shares breakfast and
enjoys a little bit of peace and quiet
that's when carderby interrupts urging
them to play another game tonight he
tells them chota will be sitting out
since he's injured but the others need
to sharpen their survival skills to make
it out alive chota then says that since
he's not playing his visas won't be
expired shibuki volunteers to stay back
with him and they agree to play another
game when he's recovered the two enter
the location for the second game and see
scary-looking participants waiting
around a voice announces that the game
has started and a bloodthirsty killer is
somewhere in the building they're told
the game that they're playing is tag and
this complex is the playground the
difficulty is revealed to be five of
spades and this well-dressed man informs
the boys that spade-based games require
physical effort the loudspeaker informs
everyone that the game will last 30
minutes and whoever is the killer will
start hunting in five minutes the
complex has one room that isn't locked
and that's the home base of the killer
if a player can reach the home base
within the time limit they'll beat the
game the game is over when the time runs
out or all the players have been killed
last but not least though the building
is surrounded by landmines to make sure
no one leaves of course okay here we go
again we're now completely familiar with
these types of death games and know that
some f'd up [ __ ] is about to happen
people are going to die and there's no
reason to be shocked in fact we need to
use them to our advantage we should try
and pick out any gullible suckers that
we can use and add them to our group of
disposable idiots there's some people
here who are experiencing these death
games for the very first time which
means we can use their inexperience to
help them if i was outer suit i would
tell the first timers that were allowed
to retry once we're killed in the game
they've all just been transported to a
random city in the outskirts of japan
and i know they're probably going to
believe anything that comes out of my
mouth this time around it seems like
whoever's making these games is using
landmines to keep us from running away
brilliant this makes the situation a lot
easier for us to escape rather than
having instant death laser beams all
around us that being said we don't know
how many landmines have been planted or
how far out the landmines extend or even
where the hell they are but i think it's
safe to assume that there's a lot of
them let's just completely forget about
the objective of the game and try our
hand at escaping we don't know if this
visa stuff is even real and it sure
doesn't seem like throwing ourselves
into more death games is the best way to
stay alive arizu and krabi are best off
convincing some dumb schmucks to test it
out and throw themselves out of bounds
to their purely coincidental death i'd
use my trusty friend karabe and tell him
to lead the way as another lifeline
however that wouldn't mean we're in the
clear just yet it's safe to assume that
these game creators have more than a few
landmines planted around the area which
means while other people are getting
massacred if we can find a heavy object
something like a fire extinguisher which
is commonly found in apartment complexes
we could throw that off of the building
as well and on the surrounding area this
will detonate to the landmines and give
us a clear pathway out of here possibly
of course this isn't a foolproof method
of surviving but thinking out of the box
is more important when our lives are on
the line arusu instantly begins
analyzing the situation at hand suddenly
they hear the sound of a door opening
and shots are fired they run upstairs to
see two players being brutally murdered
the killer turns to them and starts
shooting forcing them to run for their
lives arizu stops his buddy and tells
them to head another direction using the
well-dressed man as a decoy and he tells
carterby to hold his breath once the
killer passes the boys run as fast as
possible away that's when arizu reveals
that the killer was dragging his foot
meaning they can move faster than him
artesu tells his buddy that now's the
time to find the home base carterby
screams out to the other players telling
them the identity of the killer and
urges them to help each other however he
doesn't realize that this is not a game
of trust this purple-haired girl tries
to warn this player about the killer but
gives up and climbs away narrowly
missing the machine gun meanwhile this
dispatch man tries to leave the play
area and gets blown to bits assuring the
others that there's no reason to leave
yet now 10 minutes have passed and
they've begun to realize that checking
each door manually is too slow arizu
faces out for a second and the killer
spots them standing around he then hides
behind the wall hoping that the killer
only noticed his buddy carter b runs
downstairs and bumps into these two
serious looking players they tell him
that they're looking for the killer and
it's time to stop running carby grabs
the killer's attention distracting him
while the others spray their fire
extinguishers that's when they signal to
the bald man and he opens the elevator
door to choke him out from behind but
suddenly the bald man is shot dead and
the killer reveals another gun he then
shoots the other man who says before he
dies he should have known there was
another gun and the killer heads
straight for karubi ardersou starts him
running away and calls out for his buddy
putting himself in danger noticing the
killer coming his way he realizes that
the man isn't after him he's only
protecting the home base the game of tag
is a cover-up to throw them off of the
real target with only one minute left
arizu knows that the killer must be
guarding the base that's when he sees
carterby coming around the corner and a
plan is put into action arizu grabs the
killer's attention while carterby sneaks
up from behind he grabs and throws the
man allowing arizu to get inside but
suddenly the horse-faced killer
reappears and is about to kill him but
this athletic girl manages to knock him
down and they both press the buttons and
the man explodes meaning they've just
won the second game later carby spots
this long-haired man looking around the
dead bodies the man explains he knows
more about this game than well most and
tells cardi b to find a working radio if
he wants information the next day he
finds a taxi radio ordering everyone to
find a nearby beach the group arrives at
the next location to find a sign for the
third game they put on these headsets
and walk inside looking around to see a
massive indoor nature zone the door's
locked and a loudspeaker announces that
it's game would time the difficulty is
revealed as seven of hearts their
hardest game yet this time they'll be
playing hide and seek one person will be
the wolf and the rest will be sheep the
players must hide from the wolf's sight
if they're caught the wolf and the sheep
will switch places the sheep then has
three seconds to disappear shot the
group realizes that one of them has to
die that's when the loudspeaker
announces that the wolf is the only
winner once the game is over the choker
around the sheep's neck will explode the
game announces the player's roles with
chota being the wolf okay this is
totally messed up but survival of the
fittest is how it goes now we know the
biggest mistake is by entering another
death game however if i'm arisu i'm
pulling at all the emotional
heartstrings of my buddy chota to make
him look at me even if it resorts to me
giving him a good hard slap if that
doesn't work then i'm taking my buddy's
head and forcibly making him look at me
if his eyes are shut i'm going to use my
thumbs and pry his lids open once that's
sorted out i'm running away as far as i
can to avoid looking at my friends and
reverting back to a sheep survival of
the fittest is the name of the game
folks and while these boys have probably
been my friends for a long time i can
always make more friends once i'm out of
here now playing a game of hide and seek
in a massively huge park forest
shouldn't be that hard of a place to
hide in there seems to be a wide variety
of creeks streams bushes that we can use
to hide it luckily for us the time limit
for the game is only 10 minutes long
that's not exactly a lot of time for the
others to find us this game isn't really
that hard all you have to do is suppress
your emotions and act like a psychopath
and imagine if you've lived through a
lifetime of trauma knowing that you've
just killed your best friends since this
indoor forest is home to a number of
tall sturdy trees we could also try our
best to climb up one of them and hold on
to it for the remainder of the game as
long as the tree is big enough and tall
enough and the foliage in the tree is
thick enough we could even take a nap on
one of the branches just like in the
jungle book while everyone else dies and
that way no one is going to be able to
catch me and change my wolf status shota
is injured karubi is too dang heavy and
shibuki's tight clothes are going to
restrict her from any kind of climbing
in general shocked artizu tries thinking
of a way out but can't come up with
anything as the wolf shibuki here makes
the biggest mistake she runs off and
karubi freaks out he pins her down to
the ground and threatens to kill her for
betraying them shibuki manages to throw
him off while he's distracted and she
looks up to chota on accident the new
wolf then runs off while arizu runs
after him chota accidentally looks at
him changing the wolf one more time he
decides to take the opportunity and
tells chota that they're no longer frets
with only five minutes left on the clock
artesu hides in the bushes to avoid the
others that's when chota contacts on the
headsets to make a dirtbag confession he
tells them that he hooked up with
shibuki while they were gone shocked
artesu screams out and realizes that the
game is tearing them apart he walks to
the front of the park and tells them to
come out if they want to be the wolf and
survive ottersu desperately tries
looking for them but all the sheep agree
to let him survive they bid him farewell
as the chokers explode on their nests
leaving him as the sole survivor the
park then bursts into flames and artesu
is left all alone he explodes in a rage
and promises to kill anyone responsible
for these games then the pink-haired
girl from earlier gives arizu her hand
and tells him to come along if he wants
to live and if you don't want to lose
all your friends like arizu don't forget
to like comment subscribe and check out
how to be playlist down below